hey guys i am just and i'm here with a
new guest two new guests hello I'm here
with Scott RS and joke from Telltale
Games alright and I'm trying to keep my
cool because holy Lord do I love
telltale Game thank you I have
effectively not kept my cool for the
last five minutes of introducing myself
so let's see how I do for the next 15
it's really been like blushing and like
washing the same like I really might
can't wait I mean like any III that
comes with more news on telltale games
I'm so damn fun we brought we brought
the the pain this year so you have
nailed it you've got two massive things
coming up you you're talking wet walking
dead season 3 yes and Batman Batman and
South Hill series holy crap were super
busy year for us you know we're trying
to build the studio and really tell
tales work to feel more like a TV
network yeah more like kinda like a
playable netflix or HBO where we're
learning from storytellers and movie
makers and show makers just as much as
we're learning from game makers yeah I
did you our own thing kind of fall
somewhere in between yeah and you know
we're trying we're building different
games in different genres yeah they all
have sort of adventure game mechanics
that were used to as you know people to
play games but people coming into the
telltale experience it's you know it's
really something for everyone's yeah I
have so much to ask you first off I'm
going to put the call out on twitch chat
i'm reading because i know so many of
you guys had so many questions so if you
have questions about walking dead or
Batman post them in the chat and I will
try and look over I love to know are we
going to see changes to the gameplay
formula obviously you guys do have a
formula but there have been changes
between each season I working I think we
people asked often about a telltale
formula yeah and we'd call it more of a
format shits formula is more you know
for us you look at stories and formula
is sort of like two guys a girl in a
pizza place yes I bear it for us going
from different genres like with walking
dead for a sort of a zombie apocalypse
drama there's a different sort of
formula to storytelling yeah and those
genres but no if you played a total game
before
you are going to feel comfortable and
understanding you're going to be making
difficult decisions yep talking
different characters and a lot of
role-playing that happens in the
cinematic telltale language yep so it'll
feel familiar but we are also making a
lot of enhancements are we upgrade our
engine this year that our lighting
effects and a lot of bells bells and
whistles yeah things are we running much
more smoothly for all of our games this
year this is a kind of a bold new step
but you know things are things are
running on every platform as well so
you're going to be playing these games
on console and on mobile tablets and
Cathy and um so lots of new things here
but so what do you want to get to face
ok under Walking Dead ok let's see
walking dead ok like we I feel like Lou
yeah well caught with what he did ok one
of the questions I got a lot of his
people want to know how long after the
events of season two ok so the third
season which we are logo doesn't even
say season three and we may fix that
later but Shaw I think at this point
it's it's sort of become an ongoing
series just like a TV show it's about
first third season yep but it's also a
new entry point so you're gonna be
playing his two characters yeah the
first is you know fans recognize her
this is Clementine she has survived and
the other is a newcomer you haven't seen
him in the comics or anywhere in the
show or the games he is from a Cuban
family and he is not with his family
right now yeah he is with Clem and you
were going to be playing as both he's
absolutely central to the story yeah and
they are really at a point in the
timeline that's kind of where that
comics are now or kind of where the show
is right now and if you played the first
season Walking Dead it started the
outbreak in Clementine was about eight
years old and by the end you found out
by talking to the stranger that she had
just turned nine yep for the second
season she was maybe about 10 or 11 yep
it's a little nebulous and as as as time
goes on yeah and as people are alone in
the woods and in the dark and you know
just trying to survive yeah it's tough
to even recognize if everyone is even
still celebrating birthdays right of
course of course but now we're a couple
more years in and
lamb is sort of inner early teenage
years so we're not quite definitive but
I'd say 13 or 14 May for clementines age
and that's how far we are in so 9 8 9 10
11 12 13 45 fish yeah fish years and
that's how far we are and now at least a
where you saw in the teaser but there's
a lot of ground to cover for what
happened to these characters yeah the
point of the outbreak in to where they
are now and I thank you lately without
spoiling anything I think narrative Lee
will be exploring a lot of ground yeah
get everyone up to speed yeah so I'm now
just like well as you were talking about
I think you my head like would it be
cool of like Ellie from the last of us
and Clem teamed up and we're like this
so I by duo lash fanfic them over here
like romantic but I mean I'm equally
excited about the walking dead yeah i
think the other question everyone had
was all the choices from season wanted
to get a matter in 30 undred percent
yeah how do percent but also it's it's
it's unique as well because are also
building a new entry point where if you
haven't played the others yeah highly
encourage you to do so of course but if
you've never played a telltale Game yet
or walking dead episode you can start
with this third season yet but obviously
a lot of things have happened and a lot
of different things have happened
especially the end of season two so no
matter where you left off we're going to
be working with really way to have
people carry their saves over from the
platform's they were playing on and if
anything's happened or if you don't have
that system anymore we're going to make
this very very easy to ensure that
you're going into the third season with
a sense that this is where you left off
individually and yeah but yes every
choice is mattered but at the same time
if if you haven't played it it's going
to be okay mm-hmm man if you saw the
teaser like even things the fans were
just mentioning this in the boards but
um Clem's missing a finger and I
mentioned this before but yes absolutely
it's that's not for everyone and that
could be tied to a decision you've wow
that you might have to make mmm or it
might be tied to decision you've already
made yeah
yeah it's already your fault so it's
okay come on no walking dead just lots
of guilt and regret and everything is
terrible your truck painting lots of
action games and shooters they track you
know where your pet shots are landing
and I got touchdowns your landing and
real really tracking all the decisions
and that making and how you're treating
people and we're keeping an eye on your
conscience clémence going a lot of
touchdowns and walking did yes well it's
half go team but yeah it's um it's our
biggest season yet it's our biggest
undertaking we haven't said anything
really about the episode likes yet or
how many there will be okay that's the
other thing I was opting comment I think
you can expect a a full-length season
yep uh akin to the first two yeah I'm
gonna shut up and let Scott asked about
that Scott no yeah I mean I know that
like we only have amount of time yeah
cool let's move on to Pat man sure yes I
mean the thing that's most intriguing to
me about Batman is that you can play
much of the experience as Bruce Wayne is
what if you could talk a little bit
about sort of the premise of the season
and how the game is going to allow
players to sort of it from what I
understand shoes if they're playing is
Bruce or his Batman yeah yeah so um gosh
where do I begin Bruce wayne/batman 75
years with the stories with this
character he's above and beyond a pop
culture icon and you know hundreds of
different actors and writers and
directors comics TV film games amazing
games it's you know he's been all over
every form of popular media and for the
left for the better part of a century
and everyone kind of gets to do their
own take on it and we've been dying to
do it for four years and we have a great
partnership with DC and Warner Brothers
and you know we've been sort of just
just itching to do this for a long time
because he's such a complex character
yeah cuz he's been through so much he's
been through this trauma he's lost his
parents and obviously he's he's not your
average everyday kid he comes from this
amazing legacy and this world this
billionaire society that's the the heart
of Gotham and he's also decided to do
something
phenomenal and unheard of and and
incredible and go out and crusade the
night and try and protect off them so he
has this really complex dual life yeah
and this fractured psyche that is just
totally right for a telltale experience
for role-playing and we've been dying to
take a do our own take on it and it's
entirely your own story it's not based
on another movie or a different show or
km or comic or anything like that it's
really based on the icon and it's our
own canon so you've always wanted to
explore more than anyone else has what
it's like to play as Bruce Wayne until a
Bruce Wayne story just as much as we're
telling a Batman story because they're
both the same person so it's uh it's
it's pretty intense and there's a lot
that we've learned from all of our
series that we've been doing for the
last few years and yeah a lot that
you'll see in here that we hope will
surprise you yeah that's fantastic so I
mean with Batman is it is it going to be
a similar sort of like gameplay
mechanics that we're going to see him
walking dead season 3 or is that
different familiar mechanics yes yeah I
will say that you know he is the world's
greatest detective as well yeah there
are a few mechanics that you haven't
quite seen in a selfie game before as
he's sort of unraveling some some
criminal activity and villainy ray um
but we do like to keep it all of the
mechanics focus on them in the narrative
so yeah we present the cinematic
narrative experience we want to keep you
immersed and the mechanics that sort of
touch on that sort of keep the flow
going and yeah you'd be thinking and
really keep you in character that's
amazing you guys have talked about the
timeline for when these are coming out
and when players can expect action butyl
play this one so for both of these yeah
so you will be playing Batman the
telltale series will be for marrying
this summer you can download it
digitally you can also buy a retail
season pass disc yeah we can download
the episodes as they're as they're
finished and that's end of the summer
probably sometime around August yeah and
then for walking dead season 3 that'll
be premiering later this fall so
sometime after school starts so before
for school Batman after school wyd that
sounds so amazing I would like to just
keep you an auskey
300 more questions I unfortunately I
have to say goodbye um but I will uh
yeah hello Quigley keep you can always
email us you can always tweet it up I
don't want i'll just send you my list
all right oh we're on the moon great you
heard a chat be sure to annoy job with
all of your telltale questions yeah
that's that's really what we're doing to
tell you as much as we can without
spoiling the story okay well I think
it's safe to say everyone is so bloody
excited thank you what you guys are
bringing out next so you do awesome
stuff and it's an author nine that does
this and yeah I'm just one of a group in
San Rafael and hello to everyone back
home thanks for working hard and my mom
hi well that's wonderful hi to
everyone's mom hahaha moms happy
Mother's dang in American accent yes
thank you so much for joining us we are
going to take a short break but we will
be right back with more fun things to
show you